يزداد التوتر على
الحدود بين إسرائيل ولبنان في هذه المرحلة،
أفادت وسائل إعلام لبنانية أن غارة جوية إسرائيلية
أصابت العديد من الطلاب في إحدى
البلدات الجنوبية حيث أصيبوا
بزجاج مهشم، وفي الوقت نفسه يقول حزب الله إنه
استهدف كيبوتات إسرائيلية وبلدة في
إسرائيل قريبة من الحدود.
يقول المستجيبون الأوائل في إسرائيل إن رجلاً إسرائيليًا
قُتل
اليوم بصاروخ مضاد للدبابات تم إطلاقه
من لبنان، انظر دعنا نوصلك إلى إيفان
واتسون الذي يربطنا من بيروت، لقد
ذهبت ذهابًا وإيابًا من غزة الآن
من تلك الحدود، آسف أه ل  أيام
أم إيفان يبدو بالتأكيد أن هناك المزيد من
الدلائل على ما هو موجود، ونحن
نكتب عن هذا منذ أسابيع
وضعًا متقلبًا للغاية على طول
الحدود الإسرائيلية اللبنانية أم ح كيف
تصفه في هذه
المرحلة، أرى أنه صراع حدودي  أمر
مرعب وأه
مقلق للغاية للأشخاص الذين يعيشون في
المناطق الحدودية وهو مميت كما
أشرت رجل إسرائيلي يبلغ من العمر 60 عامًا
قُتل اليوم على الجانب الإسرائيلي من
الحدود رصاصته اليوم أعلنت
مقتل ثلاثة على الأقل من مقاتليها  لا نعرف ملابسات
كيف أو أين أو متى حدث ذلك أه
قالوا أن أحد مقاتليهم أه
أعلن أنه قتل أمس أه
الجيش الإسرائيلي ندم
على جندي لبناني قتل
أمس ورغم أن هناك الكثير  أه أه
أسلحة فتاكة يتم إطلاقها ذهابًا
وإيابًا عبر الحدود من
الواضح جدًا أنه لا حزب الله ولا
الجيش الإسرائيلي لم يستخدموا بعد
أقوى أسلحتهم
التي كنا سنرى أمثالها في
شهر 2006 الأكثر فتكًا  حرب
بين هذين الخصمين، لذا فإن ما
يوحي به هو أن كلا الجانبين
يتراجعان إلى درجة معينة وقد
أشار حزب الله إلى أنه اقترح
أن جزءًا من هدفه الرئيسي أه في هذا
الصراع الآن هو في الأساس تقييد
الجيش الإسرائيلي للحفاظ على
قدر معين من القوات الإسرائيلية من أن
تكون قادرة على المشاركة في
الهجوم القاتل المستمر في غزة مع
حملة مضايقات
على طول الحدود الإسرائيلية بشكل أساسي ولكن الأمر
مستمر منذ شهرين الإسراء أه
وزارة الصحة العامة اللبنانية أه
تقول ذلك وفقا ل  الإحصائيات
أعتقد أن حوالي 96 شخصًا
قتلوا في هذا الصراع 94 حتى الآن
على الجانب اللبناني من الحدود
مع عشرات الآلاف من
النازحين لذا إذا كنت مرة أخرى أحد
هؤلاء السكان أه من إحدى هذه
القرى العديدة على طول الحدود أه  ربما سماع
أنك جزء من استراتيجية
لتقييد الجيش الإسرائيلي
ولم تحصل على صوت أو صوت في
هذا الأمر ليس مطمئنًا جدًا
لبيكي